The correct answer is 6 for the following missing links:
this guy here gives me two values in the matrix.
This guy here another two.
And this link here is also missing. That's another two. So 6 values are missing.
Let's prove it to ourselves. Moving from x0 to x1 fills up this area.
From x1 to x2, this area.
Seeing landmark L0 from x0 and x1 means we fill these guys over here.
and the main diagonal there.
Seeing the other landmark from x1 and x2 means we fill these guys over here.
Let's count the ones that are still open, and here are the ones.
My answer was actually wrong. It's 8.
I overlooked there is no direct link from L1 to L2 either.
My apologies that I gave you the wrong number,
but it proves to you this is actually not an easy question. It's harder than I thought.
The reason is there is also no direct link that constrains L1 and L2 directly.
Landmarks can't see, so they can't put a direct link between any two landmarks.
Or put differently, in this part over here our matrix will always be a diagonal matrix.